As we discussed, one way to see
the subtlety of the difference between
problems in P and
those that are in NP-complete,
is to compare what it takes to solve
seemingly similar real world problems.
Consider the shortest path problem.
You're given two locations, and
you want to find the shortest
valid route between them.
Your phone does this in a matter of
milliseconds, when you ask it for
directions.
And it gives you an exact answer,
according to whatever model for
distance it is using.
This is computationally tractable.
On the other hand consider
this warehouse scenario
where a customer places an order for
several different items.
And a person or
a robot has to go around and
collect them before going to
the shipping area for them to be packed.
Of course, we want to do
this as quickly as possible.
This is called the traveling
salesman problem.
And it is NP-complete.
This problem also comes up in
the unofficial guide to Disney World
which tries to tell you how to get to
all the rides as quickly as possible.
This explains why your phone
can give you directions, but
supply chain logistics,
just figuring out how things should be
routed is a billion dollar industry.
Actually however we don't even need
to change the shortest path so
much to get a NP-complete problem.
Instead of asking for the shortest path,
we can ask for the longest simple path.
We have to say simple so we don't
just run around in cycles forever.
That also would give us
an NP-complete problem.
This isn't the only possible
pairing of similar P and
NP-complete problems either.
I'm going to list some more.
If you aren't familiar with
these problems yet, don't worry,
you will learn about them
by the end of the course.
Vertex cover in bipartite
graphs is polynomial, but
vertex cover in general
graphs is NP-complete.
A class of optimization problems called
linear programming is NP, but if we
restrict the solutions to integers,
then we get and NP-complete problem.
Finding an Eulerian cycle in the graph,
where you touch each
edge once is polynomial.
On the other hand,
finding a Hamiltonian cycle that touches
each vertex once is NP-complete.
And lastly figuring out
whether a boolean formula
with two literals per
clause is polynomial, but
if there are three literals per clause,
then the problem is NP-complete.
So you see,
problems in P aren't always easy to
tell from those that are NP-complete.
Yet in the real world,
when you encounter a problem,
it's very important to know
which sort you are dealing with.
If your problem is like
one of the problems in P,
then you know that there should
be an efficient solution.
And, you can avail yourself of
the wisdom of many other scientists
who have thought hard about how to
efficiently solve these problems.
On the other hand, if your problem is as
hard as one of the NP-complete problems,
then some caution is in order.
You can expect to be able to find exact
solutions for small enough instances.
And you may be able to find
a polynomial algorithm that
will give you an approximate
solution that is good enough, but
you should not expect to find an exact
solution that will scale well.
Being able to know which situation you
are in is one of the many practical
benefits of studying complexity.